- All right, "Key & Peele," this
Vandaveon and Mike again, man.
We watched the show again.
Y'all ain't got back
to us yet, man.
I'm just saying.
I don't know
what the deal is, man.
Y'all should at least
look at the critiques,
'cause in last night's episode,
y'all had a scene
that could have been
so much more funny.
- That shit was stupid.
- Hi, yeah,
it's a very historic day
for civil rights
and for gay Americans...
- Whoo!
- And Americans
all over the country.
- We gonna get married!
- Well, no, wait--
- Yeah!
- We said that'd be
a conversation,
you know what I mean,
because we didn't know this
was gonna pass so darn fast.
- That dude was gay,
and he was trying to make
the other dude gay,
or something like that,
I don't know, man.
But he was funny.
And I'm like, why not make
the scene more funny, dawg?
- They got to make
that other dude gay, too.
- See--
[laughing]
- Make that other dude
gay, too, so...
'Cause they both--
- See, that shit is already
funny, just he said it, man.
I mean, I don't know which one
of you is Keele
and which one of you is P,
but whichever
the tall dude is, man,
your thing is, man, I could see
in the whole scene
that you was uncomfortable,
right?
- 'Cause he wasn't gay.
'Cause he didn't get
to be a gay dude.
Like, he was--I mean, I could
see in your own brain and shit
that you was thinking,
"Man, why did the other dude
get to be gay?
Why don't I get to do
any of the fun stuff?"
- The dick, man.
- What?
- Slap him with the dick.
- Yeah, yeah, man.
It's like, at least
if I had been gay,
I could have slapped him
in the mouth with my dick.
- [laughs]
- That shit would have been
funny as hell,
if he was just, like,
talking there,
like, "Hey, man,
better get up off me."
both: Blip!
- And just smacked him
in the mouth with his dick.
That would have been my shit.
- You being stupid,
nigga.
You being stupid.
Quit being stupid,
nigga.
[mumbling]
- What the other problem is,
man,
is, the dude who could
have been gay,
you could have given him
all nice kind of things to do.
Man, he couldn't have been
like this and shit.
The one nigga could have
just been like this,
"We getting married,
we getting married.
"Nigga, put your dick
in my face.
Put your dick in my face."
- Being stupid, nigga.
- That's a joke.
Another thing you can do, man,
is, like, at the end,
you know, like, the one dude,
maybe if he had done--what?
- Some--the girl
with the pussy.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
Go tell 'em, man,
'cause you do it
better than me, man.
Do it.
- I ain't trying
to be on TV, nigga.
- All right, so anyway,
the girl, the reporter,
at the end of the scene, man,
where she on the thing.
Like, the dude
who's not gay at all,
he should look at her
and be like,
"Hey, man, you want
to get together later, man?
And she's like,
"No, man, I'm a lesbian.
I'm gonna leave here right now
and go eat some pussy."
[laughter]
- This nigga
talking about...
[laughter]
You stupid, nigga.
- "See, I'm a lesbian.
La-la-la-la-la."
[laughter]
- Then slap--slap him--
slap him in the face
with the pussy.
Slap him in
the face with the pussy.
- Then see her
take the pussy out
and then, blip, and slap him
in the face with the pussy.
If you hired us, we wouldn't
have missed that, dawg.
- Second draft.
- We wouldn't have missed that,
man.
- Two drafts.